mais la divergence ici jamais vue comme
ça auparavant jamais la magie qui les a
amenés à la vie s'épuise Teddy et
Dexter ils agissent tous bizarrement en faisant je
ne pense pas que c'était de sa faute je suis Larry
je ne blâmerai jamais un singe  tous les jours et il
a une nuit, ces gars dépendent de moi pour les
sauver tous, tout pourrait s'arrêter et
cela ne reviendra peut-être jamais, nous devons aller à
Londres pour comprendre cela ohmy Museum
Je suis Larry Daley d'histoire naturelle New
York doit être comme whoa  méchant être un
agent de sécurité en Amérique est encore parti
avec un silencieux avec vos épées de ninja
ce n'est même pas un peu vrai
Teddy bon homme en crise Attila d'
accord un peu de muscle Dada
non non je ne suis pas ton Dada oui nous nous
ressemblons oh non  délicat arrêtez ça cet endroit
se réveille pour la première fois et nous
n'avons aucune idée de ce qu'il y a là-bas Je pense
qu'il est prudent de dire qu'il y avait un peu de
problème
monsieur launcelot à vous zéro
Roosevelt président des États-Unis
Je n'ai aucune idée de ce que cela signifie
tout cela sera mort  par Sunrise ne débat plus jamais de la
vie Je suis affamé en retard à la
fois dégoûté et reconnaissant pour le
singe dans le défi ce n'est pas responsable
nous le suivons juste c'est ce
qu'être dans le défi signifie
jamais fuir un gros chat beaucoup
[Musique]
Nuit au Musée  le secret de la tombe
sais ce que tu as à faire c'est
vrai assurez-vous qu'elle reste là-dedans qui
pourrait être un modèle si elle n'aimait pas
tant la pizza
toi